es ist genau 11 uhr 11 und jetzt möchte
ich ihnen hier vorstellen dass nämlich
das ist das kölner dreigestirn zeigen
wir ihnen kölle alaaf an diesem 11 11
nein das ist es nicht das ist doch mein
kollege tim specks das ist doch nicht
das dreigestirn aber jetzt geht's
durcheinander und wir wissen auch warum
denn da ist feier laune aktuell in köln
ich will ihn trotzdem noch einmal zeigen
dass drei gestandene das ist eine
richtig dicke geschichte an diesem 11 11
um 11 uhr 11 gibt es halt kein kölle
alaaf wie sonst der prinz nämlich der
hat corona und bauer und jungfrau sind
damit auch raus jetzt um 11 uhr 11 die
müssten nämlich in quarantäne also da
läuft es nicht richtig am elften elften
so etwas wie ein super-gau für diesen
kölner karneval die große karneval krise
von köln tim spex dort mittendrin in
köln auf mohammad ist köln jetzt
carnevals krisengebiet oder wird er doch
im grunde gefeiert wie sonst bring uns
auf den stand
yalla fonds könne oder wie man im rest
von deutschland sagen würde hallo aus
köln wir kommen sehr sehr pünktlich denn
gerade vor ein paar sekunden bis
tatsächlich diskussion hier eröffnet
worden 11 tausend jecken feiern hier auf
dem heumarkt das ist sozusagen der
hotspot dieser session zur eröffnung und
ja die stimmung gewesen als games
eigentlich kein grüner dir die leute
stehen die leute feiern sie tanzen sie
singen sie schon
und jetzt vielleicht um da gerade ab von
thema fleck können wir noch mal rüber
gehen ob tim wieder für uns schaltbar
ist ich würde gern noch eines wissen wie
das da mit dem prinzen und corona was
das für auswirkungen jetzt hat auf euch
also ich hab gerade schon vom kampf als
in diesem gebiet dort gesprochen in köln
ist davon irgendwas zu merken dass der
prinz aus stechen jetzt am 11.11 uhr
ohne hut und bauer und jungfrau eben
auch rein mussten in die quarantäne
nein davon ist hier nichts zu merken die
sollten eigentlich in ungefähr 20
minuten hier auf die bühne kommen aber
das ist im moment das einzige was wir
sozusagen merken wird gleich dass die
drei eben nicht kommen ansonsten hier
nichts von krise zu spüren die leute
wollen feiern egal ob ihr dreigestirn
auftritt oder nicht die haben bock
offenbar wieder den karneval zu feiern
alle sind ja auch chemisch oder genießen
sie fühlen sich sicher die leute mit dem
ich reden konnte und die sagen ja es
muss weitergehen und da ist auch egal ob
der prinz eben gestern abend positiv
getestet wurde
starkes christ übrigens wie kannst du
auf die idee als ein hund zu gehen
ja danke ich ihr wisst ihr ja
ich bin doch tatsächlich nicht das
einzige einhorn hier laufen auch einige
ein um mich herum mit wisst ihr in köln
da kann man helfen helfen und auch in
der karnevalszeit einfach mal sein was
man will offenbar wollte man inneres
nicht mal ein einhorn sein da habe ich
die gelegenheit beim schopfe gepackt und
bin halt eben heute ganz in pink und
damit habe ich auch so ein bisschen
lange geltungssucht vielleicht
beschädigt er du kannst alles klein auf
ist ein einhorn dann sei ein ganz
wichtiger schritt
heute stimmung in köln ich kann mich
überhaupt gar nicht trennen sagt mir du
hast mit vielen feiernden gesprochen wie
einst frau cora ist heute wieder waren
sind zahlen die steigen und steigen
viele machen sich sorgen auch auf ihre
impfungen noch als auf der booster rein
muss ist von dieser sorge überhaupt
etwas zu spüren oder legen sie könne das
heute einfach mal ab
ja sie scheint es ein bisschen abzulegen
und zu dieser frage können wir auch
einmal die mathis fragen der mattes den
spreche ich einmal noch mal andermatt
ist krieg hatten frisches kölsch hatte
stoner die zahlen steigen die
infektionszahlen trotzdem wird ja heute
mit tausenden jecken gefeiert wie ist
das für dich ist das in ordnung alles
vollkommen in ordnung für mich bin froh
wieder foster laufen feiern zu können
ich bin oft kontrolliert heute
kontrolliert worden heute und das gibt
mir recht sicher doch und hast du keine
angst sich bei diesen tausenden jecken
hier ohne maske zu infizieren eigentlich
wirklich nicht wir sind alle geimpft
dann super zweig haben heumarkt und
schön mich sicher bisher innere maske
angezogen wird zurückgehen die maske
wieder an von daher alles ist gut ich
fühle mich gut
ja er hört also die hätten die sind hier
sich einig die fühlt sich gut die fühlen
sich sicher gerade wegen der kontrollen
wegen der zweijährige und hoffen eben
einfach dass das hier gut ausgeht und
kein superstar der event wird